six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's go next to our caller from the 901
area code caller from 901 who's this
where you calling from did you say your
name is Ben
yes all right go ahead Ben I'm sort of a
new viewer of your channel and I kind of
value it for its more objective and
reasonable take on things thank you
but a recent video kind of made me
afraid that you want to pressure maybe
the theme as objective as possible and
that is the Alexandria
Acacio Cortez okay that so I really
agree with you on your second point
which is about a tweet where she kind of
uniformed on junior my my take on that
was it was more of a political mistake
than a legal issue okay but the first
week you you mentioned missing money and
that's really nothing she ever said in
her place yeah we we followed up on this
a couple of times you can certainly make
the case that she wasn't literally
saying used the missing Pentagon money
to pay for health care and that she was
just pointing out how the amount that
would be needed for Medicare for all is
not that much bigger than what we sort
of accept as accounting errors on the
Pentagon's side I understand that that
that's certainly you know that's a very
charitable reading of the tweet that
could be issued but you know I think
without relitigated that because we've
already done that in a couple of phone
calls what I'm more interested in is
when you say when you say that you like
my objectivity but that the Alexandria
Acacio Cortes clip made you question
that a little bit what do you mean what
do you how do you define objectivity
well that didn't really that made me
seem like you're you were feeling
pressure to seem objective by countering
someone that people perceive as being
underside and who would be
assuring me to do that I think you would
feel your own brain it's not like an
external force like paying yours I'm
just saying that you just you know you
want your shell to be as objective as
possible and come off that way
and to do that you sort of decide to
take on something that perhaps didn't
really you know needed and is
objectivity bad oh no no I just thought
that that that in particular wasn't so
objective it was just like a
manifestation of an attempt to seem
objective right I think this is a good
opportunity to mention that there's
often confusion between neutrality and
objectivity right so I think that what
what I hear you saying is that I did I
may have you believe I may have done a
segment criticizing Alexandria Castillo
Cortes out of an effort to appear
neutral as if I just criticized
everybody equally that's very different
than objectivity right you can be
neutral when reality is not neutral so I
could say I'm neutral between climate
science and climate skepticism I don't
think that would be particularly useful
objectivity I think should be applauded
which is I'm not going to let let
partisan politics blind me from
criticizing someone when I believe
they're saying the wrong thing now you
could say I don't think she said the
wrong thing or I think you're
misinterpreting it but I think this is a
really important media literacy thing
let's make sure we understand that
neutrality is a sort of concocted
position that one can have whereas
objectivity is trying to evaluate facts
without allowing biases to cloud your
judgment if that distinction makes sense
correct yeah I guess in this context I'd
say you were gearing into neutrality for
the sake of object okay yeah disagree I
mean I think that I've never shown I
think you would be hard-pressed to make
the case that I have attempted to be
neutral on the program for the sake of
being neutral in fact I've made it clear
this is a progressive show but I need to
be a object
based on my values and my analyses of
issues but I appreciate you letting me
know and this is this is an interesting
conversation that that we'll keep having
thanks for the call one of the day's
sponsors is privacy comm slash Pakman
which is a free service that I myself
use really useful in many different ways
takes just a few seconds to link your
debit card to privacy comm then you can
create virtual credit cards that are
linked directly to your bank account and
you use those virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card so that
it's not spread all over the Internet
and one of the best things about it is
how their mobile app and browser
extensions for Chrome and Firefox make
it really easy to use let's say for
example that I'm signing up for a david
pakman show membership in the credit
card number field I already see the
privacy comm icon I just click it choose
which of my virtual credit cards I want
to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy calm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time it
is all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link